what's with the jeans pretty cool I'm
pretty cool feel it I feel it you know
like your hat today on top oh thanks
Hiller my boy El Chapo oh yeah you're a
huge fan oh yeah man me and Sean Penn
are tight how great was that interview
with Sean Penn he's retarded
he's retarded he's a well-meaning retard
man a lot of actors are yeah their
emotions get in the way of their their
minds actually functioning mm-hmm
you know he means well yeah I feel
complicit he was so far so fired up
about the war on drugs and you know he
feels complicit and okay but you know
why he's so fired up because he's been
sniffing Robin Wright's asked for how
many years well at this point he hasn't
in a while you know I mean they've been
they've been split for quite some time
yeah I think it's bracelet basically its
withdrawal of not he understands drugs
because he sniffed that butthole for so
many years that he's probably like you
know I feel I feel compelled to take a
really risky trip just to get those
Buttle whiffs again now we watch The
Princess Bride the other night and
that's like vintage Robin right and I
just want you two to decide do you like
the vintage Robin right her butthole or
current Robin right two different
battles two completely different bottles
yeah and to me it's no competition
I went current current Robin right
buckle really threw this why I like that
season whole I like you know see she's
so much more confident I mean she's kind
of a pushover and The Princess Bride I
never liked broads like that right now
as the first lady I feel like she's just
ripping it up and she's just you know
she's on all fours and she's got a
collar around my neck okay and she's
pulling on the leash okay and she's
making me eat more and more and more and
that's kind of Robin right I've that's
the one grown to love yeah yeah well I
also think she's gonna really she's on a
very strict diet I mean there's not an
ounce of fat on she looks great I mean
how old is she have to be gotta be nifty
yeah at least 50 amazed she's on that
vegan diet for sure yes listen let's go
but I bet she doesn't eat meat she's
probably like pescetarian or something
like that no dairy
she doesn't need areas she doesn't eat
meat 49 Wow turning 15 April do you
think her butthole really tastes
different than it did in the Princess
Bride
I think this age change the flavor of
your butthole I think it has to I think
it has to I think yeah I think she
probably has a I don't want to say game
ear but just it's not her tonight it's
not gamey it's just I don't know it's
just you know when a restaurant has a
grill that's been there for a while yeah
you don't change the grill you don't
wash their boots for the flavor like
don't wash the skillet like my bazooka
wipe exactly you just wipe it why and
they go well it contribute like yeah we
were to clean this completely some of
the cooking that some of the flavors
that you taste in our cooking would just
we can't replicate yeah that's what's up
with Robin Wright's ass well I think
you're right on that I think it's the
kind of asshole that you know you wipe
it but you want to wash it